eine raumstation in einem ausgehöhlten
asteroiden humbug oder realistische idee
ein team aus astrophysikern und
physikern hat jetzt berechnet ob dieses
science fiction idee umsetzbar wäre und
das ergebnis ist mehr als überraschend
wie also können wir uns eine raumstation
in einem ausgehöhlten hast du ihnen
vorstellen
giggs 1 1 in fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen manche
fachleute sind sich sicher das
sogenannte space mining könnte mal einen
der größten industrien des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts werden
das potenzial ist jedenfalls gegeben
berechnungen zufolge könnte nämlich ein
etwa ein kilometer großes objekt den
heutigen bedarf an industriemetallen
decken und das für jahrzehnte die nasa
geht davon aus dass allein im
asteroidengürtel zwischen jupiter und
mars gold nickel und eisen im wert von
achtung 700 quintil ionen dollar zu
finden sind 710 millionen das sind
unglaubliche 20 0 hinter der sieben
braun und mittlerweile ist an dem thema
nicht mehr nur die nasa dran sondern
auch weltraum bergbauunternehmen und
auch einige start-ups und so gibt es
schon jetzt geschäftsmodelle für den
weltraum bergbau
das langfristige ziel ist es dabei nicht
nur material abzubauen und zur erde zu
bringen
die rohstoffe könnten außerdem auch
direkt im weltraum genutzt werden und
zwar für aufenthalte dort unter längere
reisen bei der umsetzung wäre eine
raumstation enorm sinnvoll und zwar
direkt an oder besser gesagt direkt in
den zielobjekten konkret könnte
beispielsweise ein teil eines asteroiden
ausgehöhlt werden dann in seinem inneren
einer raumstation aufzubauen
das hätte direkt einige vorteile die den
abbau von rohstoffen enorm vereinfachen
würden im inneren eines astor jeden
beispielsweise wären die astronauten vor
der kosmischen strahlung geschützt und
nach dem abbau der rohstoffe könnte man
den asteroiden in rotation versetzen
damit würde dann eine künstliche
schwerkraft erzeugt das sind erst einmal
nach science-fiction pur
doch völlig ausgeschlossen ist das ganze
projekt keineswegs astrophysiker und
physikerin der universität wien haben
diese zukunftsvision jetzt einmal
genauer analysiert als basis für ihre
berechnungen haben die fachleute einen
hypothetischen asteroiden mit einer
größe von 500 x 390 metern
ausgewählt der künstlich in rotation
versetzt wird also eben solch einer
größenordnung existieren tatsächlich in
der nähe der erde das physikerinnen und
physiker team benennt in seiner studie
beispielsweise 3361 orpheus und 999 42
apophis in den hypothetischen asteroiden
aus silikat gestein würde laut den
berechnungen ein hohlraum geschaffen und
zwar in einer größe von 200 x 300 metern
hier könnte dann eine raumstation
errichtet werden damit die gesundheit
der astronauten teams dort nicht
gefährdet wird müsste der asteroid laut
der experten und expertinnen ein bis
drei mal pro minute um seine achse
rotieren
dies hätte eine schwerkraft zufolge die
der schwerkraft auf dem mars ähneln
würde etwa 38 prozent der schwerkraft
auf der erde nämlich dazu thomas mandl
aus dem österreichischen forschungsteam
unsere berechnungen zeigen dass die
belastungen durch fliehkräfte eine
raumstation in so einem massiven möglich
machen ohne dass spannungen zu einem
zerbrechen des körpers führen
doch die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler betonen auch dass ihre
berechnung nicht als basis für eine
endgültige entscheidung geben können ob
sich solch ein objekt tatsächlich für
den einbau einer raumstation anbietet
könnte allein eine mission vor ort
zeigen diese würde dann auch wichtige
erkenntnisse zur inneren struktur und
zusammensetzung des asteroiden liefern
die uns bislang noch fehlen
die größten gefahren aus dem weltraum
draufklicken anschauen und astro comic
tv abonnieren cola kanal ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran